this is our last week spending our last
day in the apocalypse my friends we've
laughed we've cried and now it's over
the only apocalypse we can enjoy now is
the one we call
life also given a spoiler warning for
the last of us I'm going to talk about
The Last of Us finale gonna talk about
everything that happens and basically if
you haven't watched The Last of Us
Series this might not be the YouTube
video you want to watch or click on I'm
not gonna stop you if you want to stick
around I mean algorithm the [__] out of
it I'm just saying you've been warned
now where this episode started out how
it opened up I'll get to in a second
funny thing for me is I was like this is
the shortest episode of the entire
series which is kind of that's amusing
to me it's like season finale shortest
episode but I guess it is pretty
straightforward Joel and Ellie they're
walking they're making small talk Jules
acting like the cool Uncle like hey how
you doing Ellie Chef Boyardee you hungry
you seem a little blue right now because
you just smashed a Cannibal's face in
with a big blade who was gonna eat you
and hey
better Chef Boyardee than you
it's all kind of awkward but they get to
the facility in which Joel is told hey
by the way just like the game it
actually plays out very accurate where
it's like yeah uh we got a killer in
order to get this cure
so you take off now Joel we got this and
I gotta say I was pleasantly surprised
with the body count that Joel racked up
in there I mean body counts not
everything but there were moments in
this show where I was like I could have
had more enemies well they could have
had more enemies I had more enemies in
the game than they had on screen unless
it's a big wave of those clickers that
were coming out of the ground other than
that this show quite often I was like
that should have been more there should
have been more enemies so I was a little
afraid for the scene where Joel goes to
this hospital I'm like I need blood I
need Slaughter I need Joel to be
Terminator from T1 when he was going to
the police station with some really
Downer somber music oh wow look at that
it's pretty much what I got so I really
liked that could have gone for more
bricks bludgeoning heads
shock that that never happened in this
show that's such a such a main weapon in
the game oh well I did like the shot
after Joel kills the doctor and he's
like all right unhook her right now when
he's leaving with Ellie there is that
after shot of the Dead doctor on the
ground because that's
pretty much what kicks off the last of
us too so yeah Jules told by the way
Ellie's going to die we have to rip this
cure from our brain too bad so sad and
Joel was like not today everyone dies
and he gets Ellie the show ends exactly
where it left off in the game now in the
beginning of this episode Ashley
Johnson's a flashback Ashley Johnson
plays Ellie's mom but you gotta love the
Poetry there it's the actor who played
Ellie playing Ellie's mom giving birth
to Ellie this is the first time that I
saw the reason behind Ellie being immune
which was her mom while she was pregnant
with Ellie Was Bitten and then she gave
birth to Ellie and now Ellie's immune
the implication being baby bump plus
bite equals immune baby which does
change the logistics of it a little bit
it takes Ellie from being this anomaly
is like we don't know how but she is
immune so there's that two there's a
formula to someone being immune skipping
past the fact that we're dealing with
the fireflies a really [__] up
organization that if they knew the
formula and the road map that leads to
someone being immune they definitely
would have recreated those conditions or
at least tried to I'm just saying but it
does hit differently seeing the road map
that led to Ellie's immunity rather than
being like Ellie has a genetic anomaly
and she's immune that's all I need to
know for me a world like The Last of Us
thrives on fear and uncertainty and not
knowing how Ellie's immune only that she
is immune I like that better as much as
I felt this show hammered home the drama
like when it wanted you to feel you felt
when it wanted you to get the you know
the knot in your throat it would get you
there I do wish it balanced action with
the drama a little more maybe that's the
advantage of a game it's like oh for
gameplay purposes you're gonna have more
action and that's why the game is just
the way to go but at a point it felt
like all the infected are gone we're not
dealing with infected anymore which does
happen to a degree in the game but
infected we're always around in the game
for the show it goes out of its way to
break down the lore of if you step on
one of these nerve endings in the ground
all the infected within a mile or
whatever they'll know where you are
that's a pretty intricate mechanic that
you see in this one episode and after
that there's just never seen again does
make it feel like oh we really need this
cure from Ellie it's like cure from what
cure from the thing we haven't seen for
half the show as much as I've enjoyed it
though it is proof positive that a
really good
narrative-based story driven action game
will never have an adaptation that's
better than the game I said this in a
video before I think it was one of the
Resident Evil adaptations where I said
video games have become so cinematic
games like The Last of Us for example
that they fulfill that cinematic need
that an adaptation would have done
before but now games just do for
themselves only difference is the game
has gameplay which is another level of
immersion that helps draw you into the
world that a live-action adaptation just
can't have and that to me is the case
with the last of us it was a great
adaptation but the source material still
does it best but in terms of adaptation
I thought the show did really well I
kind of see the show as The Last of Us
for your parents or other people who
just don't play games I say parents
because that's my natural inclination my
parents don't get my dad plays a living
[__] out of Tetris but that is it so I'm
saying like for people who haven't
touched a game since they felt the real
tragedy of making it through Bowser's
Castle and they're like oh God he throws
axes too then they never touch the game
since but the story of The Last of Us is
still good and you feel like they should
experience it now there's a series for
you to show them so in the end the
series of The Last of Us I thought it
was really good I've enjoyed watching it
weekly I've enjoyed doing videos on it
weekly I don't envy the task of adapting
too all right so the last of us the
finale the series all of it have you
seen it what did you think about it
that's phrase weird why would you watch
the finale without watching the series
The implication is there whatever moving
past it whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]